so the first one is just a pretty great
question to start off time travel which
is it's coming from Facebook from a guy
named Shawn Karp on Facebook
Shawn Karp Shawn harp and the question
starts what is time really nice intro it
continues what is time and especially
he's not satisfied with just not
satisfied this is not a you don't see oh
there's a paragraph here so he's not
satisfied with anything okay let's go so
what is time and he says in a sound of
thunder by ray bradbury he speaks of
time as a linear thing which can be
altered
however in Star Trek the 2009 he points
out Star Trek time is also linear but
can't be diverted into parallel streams
like a river or a highway the doctor
refers to time like this people assume a
doctor isn't Doctor Who i assuming yes
unless it's just his own personal
physician launching into the physics of
time tell you about talking first you
know in the middle of a proctology
example let's talk about time forcing
the doctor refers to time like this
people assume that time is a strict
progression of cause to effect but
actually from a nonlinear non-subjective
viewpoint it's more like a big ball of
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff and he
says are any of these explanations more
true or none even close other thoughts
well ok excellent and the beautiful
reference there with three sources of
science fiction including the late Ray
Bradbury that's right in fact so so time
all we can tell you a time is how we
measure it and what consequences
different phenomenon and behavior the
universe have upon it so here we are
sort of progressing through time second
after second and we're prisoners of the
present forever moving between the past
in the future that's how we think of it
however if I set you into motion the
very clearly identified and well tested
laws of relativity tell you that I can
slow down or speed up your time relative
to other things around you so time in
that sense is not linear it can be
stretched or
relative to other things that are around
it and not only that in the vicinity of
supermassive black holes that distort
the fabric of space and time because the
fabric of the universe is not just what
it does structurally to the space it's
the fabric of what the time is doing as
well so imagine two black holes ready to
collide
that's an awesome disturbance in the
fabric of space-time and so a black hole
a black hole is an area where there the
light a the energy in it is traveling
faster than the speed of light well no
so once you fall into a black hole
you never come out not even if you are a
beam of light so so that's why it's
black and that's why we sensibly call it
a hole so if you think I'm like a beam
of light struggling to get out of a
drain and it's not even getting it it's
not even getting up therefore it's black
and so the consequence of this it's it's
not just simply if the light can't get
out of space curves back upon itself so
that the light is trying to get out but
there is no pathway for it to occupy and
that is a severe curvature of space and
time and so of these three definitions
here as represented in science fiction
I'd have to go with the doctor and the
series doctor who write a wiggly
probably why me yeah wiggly wobbly tiny
wine and stuff yeah it's it's now about
where the time can split we simply don't
know is there some other universe where
you are left-handed and not right-handed
that split at some point in your we just
don't know right we just got out of the
one we have a hard enough time trying to
understand our one unit first yeah much
less rivers that might flow from it
people have that I think they people
have that fantasy of oh if I had another
life I would do this and they're hoping
that that life is actually going on
somewhere yeah in another universe so I
go with the Doctor Who on the back again
and when